hello everyone and welcome to a very
important game that was played yesterday
in the bullet Chess Championship Grand
Final between Magnus Carlsen and Hikaru
Nakamura the entire match was absolutely
spectacular if you have time to to watch
the uh most of you probably already have
but it's definitely worth watching you
can see by their their ratings uh 33 9
and 33 for three uh that they are evenly
matched and this is the uh well uh I I
don't want to spoil too much but one of
the last or maybe even the last game
that was played in the event and the
current result is 16 uh to 15 in
hikaru's favor so Magnus needs a win in
order to bounce back now bear in mind
this is one plus zero bullet there is no
increment and uh I mean players are
playing such incredible chess that it's
um it's it's hard to believe that it's
even possible to do this with so little
time on the clock so that being said
let's check it out Magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with E4 and Hikaru
again opts for his a modern defense with
Ponte G6 uh uh as he has in so many
other games we have Knight to F3 Bishop
to G7 D4 and now Pawn to D6 with Bishop
to D3 and Knight to F6 players the
castle we have castles castles H3 and
Knight to C6 all been played before
nothing new here C3 we have E5 and Rook
to E1 with rook d8 and now Knight B to
D2 and here the top move is Knight to H5
then you also want to bring your knight
over to F4 you can play F5 you can do a
lot of stuff D5 has been played H6 is a
known move but here we have Pawn to B6
by Hikaru and it is now as of move uh
nine that we have a completely new game
so Magnus continues a knight to F1 he
wants to re-maneuver the Knight the G3
A6 uh sorry not A6 First bishop to B7 uh
we have Knight to G3 and now A6 with
Bishop to E3 and now Pawn to H6 just
playing useful moves uh Queen to D2
developing the queen connecting Rooks
and now King to H7 we have faunted D5
and now Knights the B8 re-maneuvering
the Knight and now okay uh you uh uh you
you got rid of the Knight but now the
Knight can come to D7 then maybe to C5
and it's gonna be very strong there so
Pawn to C4 Knight B to D7 and now Pawn
to B4 not allowing Knights to C5 uh
Hikaru challenges the B4 pawn and Magnus
defensive we have captures captures and
pawn to C5 now so okay you prevent the
Knight to C5 uh but now yeah Pawn to C5
we have captors captures and queen to C2
we have Queen to C7 Hikaru also connects
Rooks and the King to H2 we have Rook
captures on A1 Rook captures and now
Rook to A8 now offering a Trader Brooks
uh Magnus goes for a rook captures
Bishop captures and now
uh Queen day for just putting pressure
on that bishop and A8 uh Bishop to B7
and now Bishop to D2 We have Knights the
B6 chasing away the queen queen to A7
and now Knight to C8 again getting rid
of the queen queen to A4 and now Queen
to D7 uh Hikaru offers the queen trade
and the Magnus except with captures uh
sorry not none doesn't accept right away
with Queen to E5 and now Bishop to f8 we
have Bishop to C3 no no idea why I
thought today they actually traded
Queens uh and now Bishop D7
and okay it's a really a mess a real
mess of a position especially for time
control where you have only one minute
on the clock uh but up to this point
players spent almost nothing like Magnus
spent some 19 seconds and he spent 14
seconds to reach this position so they
still have plenty of time with Knight to
D2 and now Bishop to Da that was the
idea behind the re-maneuvering of the
bishop uh Queen to A1 and now Knight to
B6
uh there's even a line I think it's in
the benoni defense where you a few and
keto your your dark Square bishop and
then you bring it all the way to d8 I
think it's called like the Great Snake
variation or something like that as the
the path of the bishop reminds of a
snake uh but okay uh Bishop to C2 we
have Queen to C8 and now Pawn to F4
opening up the position here he captures
and now Bishop captures on F6 we have F
cappers and G3 with check King
characters and not Knight to D7 putting
pressure on the bishop here so Magnus
trades with Bishop captures Queen
captures and now Knight to F3 we have
Queen t7 and queen to A7 now putting
pressure on the bishop and it's very
useful having the queen on the seventh
rank as absolutely everything uh Hikaru
has is on the seventh rank so Knights
the five the queen also defends the
bishop here and now comes King to F2 uh
you're uh probably wondering why just
give up the the C4 Pawn there's no good
way to defend it however you try you're
just gonna get destroyed to give you a
funny line a little Play Bishop to B3
and it's such a silly move because your
Bishop was really beautiful here Knight
captures on F3 G captures and now Queen
to E5 with check and you're just dead
lost it doesn't matter what you if King
G2 just Queen to B2 check picks up the
bishop other moves aren't much better
and also once the bishop is uh removed
the queen also guards the bishop on B7
so there's that so King death two by
Magnus and now Hikaru snatches up the C4
pawn bishop to D3 and not Knight the B2
attacks the bishop we have Bishop to A6
so hikar will lose the bishop on B7
that's why one of the reasons why Magnus
allowed this but Hikaru says not a
problem Knights the D1 with check King
to G1 and now Queen captures an E4 with
check Magnus wins the bishop Queen
capture some B7 and now Queen to E3 with
check King to H2 Queen to F4 with check
with King H1 Knights the F2 with check
only move King to G1 and now Hikaru
picks up the H3 Pawn also with check so
GC actress and now Queen to G3 check
first you could also capture but this
way you're gonna pick up the Knight with
check King F1 Queen captures an F3 with
check King T1 Queen E3 check Bishop back
to E2 and now of course you will use
this diagonal turn uh Checkmate the
white king uh as long as you want so
Queen to C1 with Chuck King death to
Queen Death for with checking you want
Queen to C1 with checking F2 Queen the
F4 with Chuck King that he won and
everyone thought that he car was just
gonna force a Perpetual uh here because
he's leading the match and it would
definitely go his way but he actually
played C4 here he wants to continue
actually being down a piece and the
Magnus should just draw this there's no
no questions asked here you just pick it
up and if Queen captures Queen captures
an F7 with check and it's a draw however
after C4 Magnus played Queen to B6 I
have no idea what it does it even you
know it does kind of look like a mouse
slip but I don't think it was maybe
Magnus saw something if you guys have
any idea behind Queen to be six I'm I'm
out I mean why would you move your queen
away from uh from this beautiful seventh
Rank and it's not like it does anything
here it doesn't guard anything or the
queen can still liver check on C1 like
okay maybe if Queen to G3 check you can
bring the queen back but again it just
looks really weird so I have no idea why
he played it but Hikaru just played Pawn
to C3 and now Magnus is dead lost
there's no way to stop the pawn uh and
that's pretty much it he played Queen to
C6 now okay you prevent upon the C2 but
now Queen to D2 check with King F2 upon
the C2 and there's no stopping C1 Queen
uh Magnus did play Queen to C7 in order
to capture on F7 to forces some sort of
a Perpetual but now Hikaru just played
Queen to F4 with the check and he was in
this position and move 58 that Magnus
Carlsen resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh he uh
his King is in check the the F7 Pawn is
defended so you don't have to worry
about that and once the king moves
doesn't really matter where you also
bring a Queen into the game and now the
queen from F4 guards the queen on C1 and
also the pawn on F7 so absolutely
spectacular it was uh quite uh quite a
thriller the entire the entire bullet
Chess Championship was quite a thriller
I mean they both played some incredible
chess Hikaru did the seem more dominant
as Magnus also dropped out then he got
back into the uh to the uh you know main
event and then he got the face Hikaru in
the Grand Final but it was always Hikaru
was the one always leading the match and
Magnus was always trying to catch up
trying to catch up and then in the end
he just couldn't uh Hikaru wins by a
two-point margin he takes it I believe
17 to 15 no uh 16 to 14. so absolutely
incredible by Hikaru and uh something
that Magnus said after the match I'm
just gonna read it to you as uh you know
I don't wanna I don't want to mess
anything up but he really really praised
Hikaru for for how strong he was uh this
is what Magnus said I played some bullet
over the years but the thing is I never
played Hikaru much and I have seen
Hikaru Crush everybody else but I always
thought that I matched up decently with
him and okay he did a match up decently
with him uh my main strength which is
also hikaru's main strength is that we
are simply better at chess than others
sounds like you know a bold statement
but you know it's it's also the truth
and that we can also make good moves
more quickly at some point he was
playing a lot faster than I was uh he
was playing much better seeing all kinds
of tactics that was a massive reality
check for me and the point and at that
point I was thinking okay he's just that
much better than I am I was like yeah
this guy is a beast and also he says I'm
extremely impressed I always knew that
he was good I always thought that he was
somewhat better than I was in bullet but
but that it was like this much better I
did not realize it's insanely impressive
and also Magnus says I think he is
certainly better maybe at my best I'm
like good enough that it's not Shock if
I win against him so there you have it a
few words from the uh from the world
champion Magnus Carlsen or rather former
world champion a former World classical
Champion but he is world champion and
other format so I guess it's still okay
to call him world champion uh but yeah a
big congratulations to Hikaru on winning
winning it all he wins the grand final
he beats Magnus in the finals and uh I
mean absolutely absolutely incredible
stuff
yeah uh that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it if you haven't seen it do
watch all of the games I mean it's
absolutely absolutely stunning to see
all of these moves being played with uh
with basically zero time on the clocks I
mean unreal I would like to think bullet
just thriller.com Gage wedland Gary
chomuk and Rod Hill for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day